[Music]  that's a cute girl like you doing  sitting all by yourself I'm waiting for  somebody  Oh waiting for me no I'm actually  waiting for my boyfriend well you know  what they say cute girl like yourself  shouldn't have to wait for anybody you  don't want it what  [Applause]  the girls guys  [Music]  I could leave you a business hey who's  that this guy literally sat down farted  and then just left  what yeah hey you yeah what are you  thinking Oh what does he think he is  anyway with that moustache  I know hate ironic facial hair  hi hey guys yeah here we made a series  it's coming on November 18 please watch  it get it here yeah yeah you got it you  can see it it'll be released 2015  November okay